that democracy is on the ballot this  year we must vote  knowing what's at stake and not just the  policy of the moment  I just keep asking myself  what does he think democracy is  I'm no political science PhD but last  time I checked democracy is what the  majority of people vote for  that's democracy that's all democracy is  it's what most people vote for when they  participate in their government  it's it's different than aristocracy  it's different than oligarchy it's  different than monarchy it's just that's  it's just what the people vote for  that's it so if the people want to elect  Republicans  and they go out and they vote for the  Republicans  that cannot be a threat to democracy  that would that necessarily by  definition is an expression of democracy  but Joe Biden doesn't seem to understand  that